As a web developer, I
know it's challenging
to stand out and
delight your users.
However, you can use
rich, animated content
to showcase a great
design or to give users
amazing visual feedback to
keep their eyes focused.
I'm Sam from Google Developers.
Here are the three modern
approaches to animation,
declarative, imperative,
and procedural.
If you'd like to
follow along at home,
be sure to check out the
description to find the source
code to the demos.
Let's dive in.
First, let's talk
about CSS animations.
These are really common.
More than half of all webpages
loaded by Chrome users
include them.
They're a type of
declarative programming
as you describe what you'd like
to see and let the browser take
care of getting you there.
Simple effects like
fades, highlights,
or other transitions
can be achieved
by setting the
transition property.
Any matching style
change will be animated
with the timing you specified.
If you've never animated
on the web before,
try it out with a
striking background color
or dismiss effect.
You can also specify
CSS key frames,
which lets you describe
a number of steps.
You'll have to specify
everything up front,
but this lets you encapsulate
more complicated effects.
The Web Animations API is
the standards-based approach
to imperative
animation on the web.
And don't just take
my word for it.
Ask the W3C.
This API provides
powerful primitives.
And we refer to this as
imperative programming
as you'll use these real
JavaScript objects directly
as part of your site's code.
You can also get started
really easily with
the element.animate() call.
By specifying a
few steps, you'll
get back an animation
object, which
lets you control an
animation as it plays, maybe
by pausing, rewinding, or
listening to its finish event.
Rather than specifying
simple steps,
you can also build
effect objects.
These are either a
list of key frames
or group of other effects.
These primitives let you
compose more complicated scenes
in any way you see fit.
Remember, because these are
real JavaScript objects,
they're perfect when
your engineering rich
object-oriented
web applications,
because they let you properly
encapsulate your animation
logic.
Lastly, there is
procedural animation.
This us actually a
type of imperative
animation, but refers to
animating step-by-step.
On the web, you can use the
requestAnimationFrame method
to be called whenever
your browser is
ready to draw your next step.
As a bonus, when the
browser is hidden,
your code won't
be called at all.
This gives you
full control, which
could be useful
when you're drawing
into a HTML canvas,
which is pretty
common for browser-based games.
However, you'd want to
keep your code short.
You'll be responsible for
orchestrating an entire scene.
So if it takes too long, your
user's experience could suffer.
Phew.
That was a lot to cover.
If you're still confused about
which approach to choose, let's
recap.
For simple effects, like
fade, highlight, or transform,
try out CSS animations and
the transition keyword.
If you're building
a web application
or to encapsulate
something complex,
try the Web Animations API.
Finally, if you
want full control,
use requestAnimationFrame
to get called whenever
your browser is ready to go.
I'll even mention that this
year's Google I/O website
uses a little bit of all three.
And sometimes that's right too.
Find out more using
these resources.
Thanks for tuning
in I'm Sam Thorogood
through Google Developers.